madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les
députés après avoir examiné
l'intégralité de la deuxème partie du
projet de doit de finance en
commission après en avoir débattu
pendant plus de 40 he en
séance nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
dans une situation que nous connaissons
malheureusement toutes et
tous d'abord la discussion de ce PLF se
déroule à un rythme particulièrement
lent s'il vous plaît s'il vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plaît l'examen l'examen de la moitié des
missions l'examen de la moitié des
missions n'a pas pu aller à son terme
si des
échanges si les échanges se poursuivent
à ce rythme il ne fait aucun doute que
nous ne pourrons pas achever l'examen de
ce projet de dois de finance dans les
temps
ensuite ensuite lors de l'examen de
certaines missions le texte a pu être
dénaturé des milliards d'euros de
dépenses des milliards d'euros de
dépenses ont été ajouté hier nous
présentons un budget ambitieux avec les
investissements nécessaires pour chacune
de nos politiques publiques je pense à
nos investissements pour l'école pour
notre sécurité intérieur pour notre
justice ou nos armées je pense à
l'investissement inédit que nous menons
en faveur de la transition écologique 40
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine 7
milliards d'euros de plus que cette
année
in mais ces investissements massifs ne
sont ne sont possibles que parce qu'ils
s'inscrivent dans une trajectoire
budgétaire soutenable une trajectoire
budgétaire qui nous permet de revenir
sous les 3 % de déficit public à
l'horizon
2027 c'est nécessaire pour notre
crédibilité c'est impératif pour notre
souveraineté milliard
enfin malgré notre volonté de trouver
des points d'accord aucun des groupes
d'opposition ne semble vouloir sortir de
sa position de principe rejeter le
budget quoi qu'il contienne je m'en
désole mais j'en prends acte nous
continuerons toujours et encore à
chercher des compromis y compris sur les
textes
budgétaires et une fois de plus et une
fois de plus nous avons choisi de
reprendre des amendements de la majorité
comme des
oppositions des
amendements des amendements qui vont
permettre des investissements
supplémentaires dans les outrmers
notamment pour les infrastructures du
quotidien pour l'emploi ou pour la
rénovation des réseaux
d'eau des amendements qui vont étendre
l'indemnité carburant à 60 % des
Français qui travaillent pour qu'elle
bénéficient mieux encore aux classes
moyennes des amendements qui vont
permettre d'accentuer encore notre lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire
d'instaurer un budget vert pour les
collectivités de renforcer la lutte
contre la pauvreté de financer des
campagnes de testing contre les
discriminations de mieux prévenir les
risques liés à la pollution ou encore de
renforcer les moyens de la recherche sur
les cancers
pédiatriques des amendements qui vont
renforcer les moyens du Mémorial de la
Choa dans cette période où les actes
antisémites augmentent faire vivre le
devoir de mémoire et d'autant plus
nécessaire
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
ne pouvons pas priver la France de
budget nous ne pouvons pas priver nos
concitoyens de leurs services publics et
des solutions qu'ils
attendent nous le pouvons d'autant moins
que nous savons bien qu'il n'existe
aucune majorité alternative capable de
s'entendre autour d'un
budget aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 à 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la deuxè partie et
l'ensemble du projet doit de finance
pour 2024 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
est insérée en annexe au cont rendu de
la présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er de notre
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
23h52 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse où une
motion de censure serait déposé la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de cette discussion
prochaine séance demain à 15h sur le
projet de loi de finance de fin de
gestion pour 2023 la séance est levée